and or may focus on the rebellion's
unsung hero but this galaxy might not be
as far far away from the Star Wars
mainstream as fans expect in the very
first episode of Andor viewers see
flashbacks to cassian's Childhood on
qunari his home planet the clips show
him Dawning combat gear and weapons to
investigate a crashed ship with the
other inhabitants of his village a
mission that ultimately proves
life-changing and not necessarily in the
best way it's interesting to see such a
young version of Cassian running around
with a spear in his hand but if you've
seen Rogue one you may have been
expecting it in the movie Cassian tells
jyn urso about his long history as a
freedom fighter have been in this fight
since I was six years old it emphasizes
just how much of his life has been spent
either on the run or in direct conflict
with the powers that be while the ship
he's investigating isn't Imperial and or
does make good on cassian's claim of
being a part of the good fight from a
very young age though the Star Wars
franchise has featured a ton of
different Starships over the decades
some have been iconic enough to stand
out anywhere even in a random Shipyard
on ferrics where Cassian is currently
living near the end of Andor season 1's
opening episode Cassian rummages around
in an old junker that he borrowed from
one of the yard's employees he plays it
cool but he's actually scrubbing
incriminating info from the ship's
records during a couple of exterior
shots of the ship viewers May recognize
a few of the other ships occupying the
yard one is unmistakably a y-wing
Starfighter a bomber commonly used by
the Rebel Alliance and first seen during
the run on the original Death Star the
faded yellow cockpit of the ship can be
seen clearly complete with the iconic
rotating turret y wings were first used
by the Republic during the Clone Wars so
it makes sense to see a stray one
junking it up on a planet like ferrics
the scene also shows what looks like a
variant of the t-47 airspeeder from The
Empire Strikes Back originally
manufactured as stunt Fighters t-47s
were modified for various purposes by
rebels throughout the Galactic Civil War
they became known as snow Speeders among
the Rebels the ship seen opposite the
y-wing in the Andor Shipyard isn't a
snowspeeder it's much longer in the back
than a normal t-47 but the cockpit and
the wing design are quite evocative one
of the most distinct aspects of the Star
Wars universe is its retro sci-fi Tech
aesthetic when the first film was
released in 1977 computers used vector
graphics as the franchise continued and
real world technology evolved Star Wars
played with different variants on its
original in-universe technology like how
the prequels employed more holographic
screens instead of the vectors and or
makes it clear from the get-go that its
inspiration comes fully from the
original old school Tech of the first
Star Wars films from the numerous
computer screens filled with hard lines
to the digital readouts on Luth and
rails binoculars the show fully Embraces
the Retro futuristic look it's similar
in many ways to the aesthetic of the
Mandalorian but with an early Imperial
era twist if you keep your eyes peeled
throughout and or season 1 you'll catch
a lot of little gadgets and gizmos that
have appeared in previous Star Wars
stories in cassian's flashbacks to the
ship crash on his Homeworld of qunari we
see how he came to be raised by Marva
Andor and taken far away into the Galaxy
it all centers around the Shipwreck
itself which Cassian investigates with a
party from his village things go sour
when some of the passengers turn out to
be both alive and hostile leading to a
violent confrontation who are these
Interlopers and where were they headed
it's not entirely clear but the familiar
logo on their uniforms gives some
indication on the sleeves of their
spacesuits you can make out the
segmented blue and white hexagon that
was the symbol of the separatist
Alliance during the Clone Wars there are
no battle droids to be seen aboard the
ship But Die Hard fans will know that
plenty of non-robotic beings gave their
lives to the separatist cause as well
this also might explain why the wounded
crewman immediately gets violent after
waking up the ship may have been coming
directly from a war zone though of
course that's no justification for his
actions when the corporate security
Agents come to ferricks to hunt Cassian
in episode 3 they come prepared not only
do they gear up with some major
Firepower but they drop down to the
planet's surface and ships that are
strikingly reminiscent of the Republic
gunships used in the Clone Wars the
iconic design was first seen an attack
of the Clones and it has remained a
staple of Star Wars ever since while
there are certainly differences between
the old gunships and the landing craft
seen in Andor their striking
similarities are interesting to say the
least in the wake of the Clone Wars The
Empire phases out a lot of the gear used
by the Clone Army old starfighters
become Tie fighters attes become atats
and the old clone gunships are nowhere
to be found it would make sense for a
private military company like the one
seen in Andor to purchase some of this
Surplus tech for its own purposes
perhaps even making some modifications
along the way that could explain the
ship design in episode 3 or maybe the
same Factor Simply Built some new models
after the war during their first meeting
in Andor episode 3 Luther rail asks how
Cassian managed to steal the untraceable
Imperial Tech he's bartering off
you just walk in like you belong to
steal from the empire
what do you need a uniform some dirty
hands and an imperial token his
explanation can be taken as a nod to the
many many times Rebels have successfully
infiltrated Imperial strongholds using
basic disguises throughout the franchise
it's a long and storied Trope worthy of
the reference whether it's Han and Luke
disguising themselves as Stormtroopers
on the Death Star or Obi-Wan Kenobi
sneaking around the Imperial Inquisitor
Citadel escorted by a double agent many
characters have walked right past the
Empire's defenses with little more than
courage and a cool hat Cassian himself
uses this exact tactic at the end of
Rogue one when he and Jen urso break
into the Imperial base on scarif to
steal the Death Star plans as such his
line about borrowing uniforms can also
be taken as a grim foreshadowing of his
eventual demise at the end of Andor
episode 3 we're treated to a beautifully
shot sequence that parallels cassian's
departure from qunari as a young boy
with his escape from ferrics with Luther
rail it's a powerful and haunting moment
showing the character's talent for
making it out by the skin of his teeth
the scene is tragic not only because it
emphasizes how Cassian must repeatedly
leave things behind but because it
foreshadows the one time he finally
doesn't make it out most people who
watch Andor will already know cassian's
ultimate fate it's particularly
affecting then to see that earlier in
his life Cassian was known for narrow
getaways so many different times he
almost meets his end only to narrowly
escape his wits take him far in his
struggle against totalitarianism but
even Cassian andor's luck must
eventually run out
foreign
[Music]